this is abir nuri's home in Flames after
an attack by a government-backed militia
in the city of omdurman in Sudan abir
knew she had to get her family to safety
if they were to have any future at
all it's not safe for them nobody can
look after them because even in the
cities around carum we used to think
we're safe now aren't people can
possibly survive but it's not safe
anymore it took almost four years for a
Beer's Asylum claim to be processed in
the UK eventually two younger children
were allowed to join her but the long
wait meant that one of her older boys
turned 18 in the interim becoming
ineligible for family reunification and
Britain's home office has refused an
appeal for compassion it says it's a
terrible feeling because they are living
on the street they have no home they
have lost everything it's an
unbelievable and Indescribable feeling
as a mom a beer story is one of many
tens of thousands people stuck in a
grindingly slow Asylum system that
lawyers say is underfunded and
underresourced the government's latest
promise to reduce a historically High
backlog of cases is they say only making
things worse they're forcing a system to
work that just does not have the
capacity the there's no capacity in the
courts there's no capacity in the home
office and there's no
capacity with legal with legal aid and
therefore yeah the rule of law is
totally is totally sort of deteriorating
meanwhile ahead of the next UK election
the domestic debate on immigration grows
ever more toxic as one former advisor to
government explains it's incredibly
toxic and actually start to view people
as individuals we may need them to be
here they may have a right to be here
and not just look at them as invading
the country or other such inflammatory
words I really think this debate needs
to be B down to a much more sensible
level but there appears to be little
political appetite for that the
government sees its policies as
vote-winning like housing Asylum Seekers
on a floating barge or plans to send
them to Rwanda none of which offers much
hope to a Beer's family her sons still
searching for safety and suffering
desperate consequences Jonah Hall Al
jazer
Bristol make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer